hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Jane secor Kevin McGuire and Andrew
piercer here to look back at the biggest
stories of the last seven days before we
get started let's get a taste of what
the week was all about Islamic state
released a video showing Jordanian pilot
Mars alcazaba being burned to death in
retaliation Jordan hand two convicted
terrorists and bombed is held territory
the US Secretary of State John Kerry and
European leaders visited Kiev to try to
broker peace talks between Russia and
Ukraine a plane in Taiwan hit a motorway
bridge and plunged into the river below
the crash killed 35 but 15 survived
rotherham council was branded not fit
for purpose in the wake of the child sex
abuse scandal in the town while new
zealand judge logo Dodd was made the
chair of the troubled Westminster child
abuse inquiry in the same week Gary
Glitter and found guilty of historical
sex offences against young girls what
would you ask the leaders 60 young
people grilled prime ministerial
candidates on tuition fees flags and
everything in between in an attempt to
eradicate genetic medical conditions the
creation of babies from three people's
DNA was approved by MPs and it might be
bitingly cold well Jimmy the groundhog
took the phrase quite literally given
the mayor of Wisconsin and nip and a
warning there's more winter to come you
know who did it what about joke about
mixing with children and animals not a
good idea that'll learn him we're though
the pictures of the week so are really
astonishing pictures of the plane in
Taiwan it looked to me it almost looks
like it was photoshopped it looks like a
disaster movie doesn't know I absolutely
stomach made in a game it's incredible
fifteen people got out alive terrible 35
died but people could survive yeah I saw
it was in the office in the background
and I didn't pay much attention because
I thought at you it was a video game
looks like it a trailer for something
and how heroic of those pilots and the
taxi driver clicked and escaped Nathan
parently passed out with fear at the
wheel which I'm sure I would have here
it's abroad right let's take a look at
the big stories of the week and a really
the big one this week Islamic state
released
a horrific 22 minute long video showing
the Jordanian pilot meijer alcazaba
being burned alive trapped in a cage
well it drew condemnation from around
the world and report by MPs found that
the UK is contributing less than its
coalition partners in the fight against
is what offense correspondent Alastair
buncle has more listening to this we
will not stop until the murderous ISIL
extremists behind this and they're
poisonous ideology are eradicated and
seeing this you would think that Britain
is throwing its full weight at Islamic
state but it's not and it can and should
do more says the defense select
committee the committee draws
comparisons with other coalition
countries and they are not flattering
Britain only has three military
personnel stationed outside of northern
Kurdish Iraq and they haven't yet made
any specific pledges to send more
compare that to 3,000 Americans 300
Spanish and 280 Italians how about
weapons or Britain has so far
contributed 40 heavy machine guns but
this is what Germany is offering up
within the list 16,000 assault rifles
10,000 hand grenades 8,000 pistols
Britain is rather more active in the
bombing campaign but even there british
air strikes only make up six percent of
the total is not a lot all in all this
is a rather bleak assessment of
Britain's military commitment to what we
are repeatedly told is a generational
struggle I think we should be doing more
or are we right to be taking slightly
stance of slightly standing back look
we've been burnt so often here none I
didn't wanna go into that horrible war
in Iraq or that terrible conflict in
Afghanistan the fact we engaged more in
bombing than others I think is
significant and Germany may be providing
all that military hardware but they're
not putting in any they're not taking
part in any bombing raids it's very
difficult the truth is of course they're
wanting money and then we've got mighty
military hardware left but certainly the
rhetoric of the Prime Minister which we
cheered it's not matter why what we do
but I look at that and I i agree i look
at the record we've been burned I think
former colonial powers terrible recorded
in recent Wars going in actually can
increase support for this so-called
Islamic state and yes sending trainers
yes sending equipment yes and the money
but I don't want to see troops they had
all see boots on the ground this week
that because the elections coming up no
nothing will change there'll be no
change in policy no change in strategy
on Iraq until after the election yeah
there's no way the Labour Party of the
livers are going to rock the boat I
because nobody certain conservatives do
not want to see bodies coming back in
bags from the latest we've got a
terrible wreck we got a terrible record
let's be honest about don't want I don't
want the position to change Iraq was an
utter disaster in 2003 we broke that
country and we helped create the
conditions in which the Islamic state is
flush we bombed Libya and Tripoli and
yes Colonel Gaddafi was a losa figure
we've smushed that country apart
Islamists are running riot the so-called
elected government does that flea
Tripoli we can't just go in you cannot
bomb countries in a democracy and try
and get them to change that but having
said that the Islamic state is the most
brutal midi port force that we've
contended it and they do have to be
dealt with let's move on and like the
tone salt with our gaffes of the week at
first up its the prime minister's wife
who's coming to fire for the company
that she works for tax arrangements this
is its mines and the posh stationers she
didn't a consultant itching to get stuck
in all this once they're able to you but
no idea they've transferred their
headquarters from Britain to Luxembourg
and let's face it they haven't done it
to pay more tax it's a bit embarrassing
for the Prime Minister as they count
their money you know the heiress loosed
always play up and said she was a very
senior figure it's else you'll now
they'll now play now player down a
rather by Darryl please like that which
it seems very British company should do
something like that yes queries here
they should pay the tax as I should
amazon i should star back to make
horrible coffee as well if they
shouldn't go down it we should want them
to pay taxes I didn't hear the Prime
Minister say that about sighs and when
he was actually quizzed about this
mountainous mittens you go there a lot I
don't know
here we go slow you're the one you're
the one with a 3,000 pound handbag lots
of gases week to get through next the
President of Argentina Cristina
Fernandez de Kirchner she's been a
mocking her Chinese hosts in the style
of a sort of a 1970s comedian she'd gone
to China on a visit tweeted did they
only come for the lice and the petroleum
I mean that is literally what a
tracksuit [ __ ] aqui she is the Duke of
Edinburgh Prince Philip does I mean it
it's just absolutely ridiculous she's
since apologized but it's too late yeah
I love that she clearly sends the tweets
herself yeah agent David Cameron having
a whiskey too many and sending a vaguely
recent usage ban on if she had one or
two advice as he was sending the tweets
they might have thought twice yes indeed
indeed write a final final avara three
gasps of the week Greg Clarke he's the
university's minister he suggested that
students can pay off their student loan
quite easily same same as the cost of a
posh coffee a day but he says a Porsche
coffee days to pound 20 let me tell you
Kevin with guys and paid more than a
pound for a cup of coffee for years
because he gets the cheap stuff but
actually it's quite they toss about to
pound fifty a day and actually a lot of
students can't afford to buy coffee well
it'll come to address the point you 60
and 80 pounds yeah a month you might pay
back in history side and that's quite a
lot of money somebody colored people
somebody calculate we take them 38 years
at this rate to pay off a debt for me he
didn't say that as it tries to justify
much everybody does Jewish politicians
who make these daftar so did they go to
university because if they did they
might have a better grasp of arithmetic
yeah but i guess it was free in those
days wasn't it onto Twitter this week
the chief executive is admitted that
social networking company sucks dealing
with trolls and that he's ashamed of how
poorly it's dealt with the issue on
technology correspondent Tom cheshire
has the details abuse can start on
Twitter with a fairly innocuous 140
characters but where it ends up can be
shocking I think first of all people
started on my physical appearance they
didn't like the way I looked well that's
fine that's I don't have a problem with
that as long as I do then I'm happy but
then it became threats and then so what
I received were sexual abuse threats
threats to harm me personally threats
saying they knew where I lived and they
were coming to get me
Sonia ended up speaking with some of her
abusers but other victims feel their
voices are being silenced by the company
CEO Dick Costolo has apparently been
listening in an internal email leaked to
a technology website he made an
extraordinary mayor Cooper we suck at
dealing with abuse and trolls on the
platform and we've sucked at it for
years it's no secret and the rest of the
world talks about it every day but
harassment isn't just a problem for
Twitter according to the pew internet
project forty percent of all internet
users have experienced online harassment
eight percent have been physically
threatened seven percent have been
harassed for a sustained period of time
and young women aged 18 to 24 are
disproportionately harassed Costello has
been under pressure from investors for
some months now with some asking if he's
the right man to lead the company this
email might have been leaked to remind
on Lucas that Twitter isn't just a
business but a messy social phenomenon
can they do though you know it's well
they're not doing anything I know but
what could they do I mean they can't
change other people think it's holding a
winger blog ideas you can block this
somebody if somebody makes a complaint
you investigate it if that account you
can see there is abuse it be racing me
sexist threats of rape violence whatever
you can block it you can block the
computer from which what's happened
isn't it you know that that comment
still come through the hurt is still
being caused the worrying thing is now
so many police officers now frontline
police officers are taking up more and
more time about complaint to do with
social media that shouldn't be there job
that should be Twitter job there make it
a lot of money out of it yeah well
that's a cost to us if police are having
to deal with that while Twitter haven't
been higher in employing the people you
can actually monitor those accounts
there is a thin line at times on freedom
of speech you can see serial abusers
have crossed that line by April reveals
the boss of a company that's been raking
in the cash and not having a proper heir
of social responsibility and they should
have some okay now time for a quiz can
you tell us what happens next and
outside of politics what experience do
you have what life experience do you
have to associate and indicate that you
should be the one to represent the
people
written I know I'm not the break Oh
welcome back to week in review with me
James Eckert and Kevin McGuire associate
editor of The Daily Mirror and Andrew
Pierce consultant editor of The Daily
Mail and before the break we asked what
happened next it was a Miliband car
crash of which there lately he was asked
about his life experience boys don't
exert let's listen outside of politics
what experience do you have what life
experience do you have to associate and
indicate that you should be the one to
represent the people of Britain well
I've done a number of things which I
think I hope are relevant to this so i
was obviously an economic advisor in the
Treasury and i think that's important i
think that's important because you know
the economy and how we change our
economy is at the heart of the country
I've taught I taught at Harvard
University I actually taught around
government and economics so you know you
know works in a shop yeah Donald yeah
just a regular girl I figure us a paper
round pulled pipes in a public eye hat
just like having done let's go round a
crisp I worked in a greengrocer it just
hasn't been he's not of the real world
but you know David Cameron could
probably said I'd polish the family
silver the gala made a joke about it as
could calamity undo us know yeah but the
in one way is refreshingly on spooner no
because because the flag and Cameron
equal of similar background what would
Cameron say when I left University got
job with the Tory party after someone
from Buckingham Palace ran the McMahon
had a word is somebody in a good job at
the PR company Clegg would say well
somebody fix me up a job in Brussels
tree on bridge what doesn't get is that
those pointy-headed answers just make
people dismay and he and kevin says he's
not spun oh he is no I'm not very good
at being say that was unspun well he was
speaking you may remember at the asked
the leaders event this was part of
standard be counted which is the sky
campaign encouraging young people to
register to vote and we did it this week
a day when 16 to 25 year olds held the
party leaders to account one by one was
good fun Jason Farrell has more
it was a first in British politics not
quite selfie young voters given access
to four leaders in one day to ask
questions face-to-face on the issues
that matter to them for the Prime
Minister the surprise contentious issue
was why we lowered the union flag for
the Saudi King we don't agree with lots
of things that the Saudis do we don't
agree with the way they treat people for
instance criminals when we make very
clear those differences but when the
King died as a mark of respect we
thought it was right to show that
respect it isn't that disrespectful to
the people who the Saudi King has
sentenced to a thousand lashes and you
mentioned that there is a release
considering the age of the audience it
was unsurprising that Nick Clegg was
attacked on his Achilles heel tuition
fees of course I've apologized for the
fact that that particular policy of my
parties we couldn't implement I
sometimes wish I only point this out I
sometimes wish i could hear an apology
from David Cameron for not implementing
his policy that he promised he would on
immigration or ed Miliband for crashing
the economy in the first place but there
you go that's the way these things are
the event was broadcast on YouTube and
throughout the day the leaders also
engaged in a Facebook debate and the
dialogue spread across all social media
they want young people to vote and this
was a way of engaging with them on their
own turf pharrell day was very exciting
and you and I was really impressed by
the the spread of questions yeah all
sorts of subjects we didn't think was
and I heard unless hope these young
people vote to but I had to say if Nick
Clegg says sometimes he wish they hadn't
done that policy he must every waking
moment times he wants to hear an apology
from you later yeah so any talked about
the toys on their immigration policy
there isn't a toy on till the new moon
craters because those wretched Liberal
Democrats in coalition have stopped them
curbing immigration they can't have it
both ways but that day proved that young
people are interested in politics maybe
they want to do it differently to how we
do it sometimes I think leaders fear
questions from them rather than from us
because they don't know where they're
coming from and that young woman who
quiz Cameron on the Saudis and the flag
hope she goes into politics actually I
wasn't quite magic let's hope don't wish
your life in politics I wish your life
is something useful and that would do
the country come on yeah at all it takes
a very shocked togo a bit ago see a
propagandist like mcguire tix is very is
very useful place socially important
Reuters I begin to San I get Miller
bells cynic light you and your a is your
to jog and they sing comfortable I can
see why you don't care the two runs
Britain matters to a lot of peace
getting more and more party heading
there right let's move on to your paper
stories of the week Andrew work we're
kicking off with about teaching the
birds and the bees as well as the ABCs a
sex education for five-year-olds this
was something label were talking about
but yeah Tristan hunt said he was
misrepresented he was talking about was
he mr. Hampton was that they always
Daily Mail dr. Tristram hunt give him
his full Monica used to be on the
television was a TV historian once sex
educator as young as five he's also
saying that teachers who were gay should
discuss her sexuality in the classroom
whatever for whatever businesses of the
classroom unless a teacher really feels
it's relevant put people under pressure
to talk about this H I don't out people
it's not what teachers about teachers
are teaching 5 to 10 year old should be
talking about reading writing arithmetic
and if they were talking about sexuality
it's not a bit young boolean it's very
young but because primary school goes up
to 11 yeah kids of 11 know quite a lot
these days that they're you know not not
through school but what they're
accessing shouldn't there be a framework
that they are at least talked about
things and that in the right way in a
factual away you know if they're talking
about two eleven-year-olds five is
ridiculous agritech ouya protest
distortion or the proposed yes it was
any Nanette it's all labour party yes
you do I mean look I mean I mean at
times your bill you're a bow I the twink
you about your about 20 store any for
these policy and your battles lummox
tear when it comes out and there was a
real ignorance because of Key Stage one
kids that's up to seven now already
talked about relationships it's
happening now let's move on Prince
Charles he's been defending himself
after a biography claimed that he'd have
a short and ugly kingship early Willie
Willie 66 now she's gonna call for some
time he's gonna be like that guy she's
good I like
mother he might go on for another 30
like Edward the seventh you'll get get a
few years but this Catherine Meyer
biography its disputed by the palace but
nevertheless it's kind of put a cat
amongst the pigeons he does come across
as pretty petty as a person what's
interesting as well at the palace
unusually wrote a letter to The Times
saying taking issue in the idea that
he's going to write a secretary my yeah
and the letter was incomprehensible of
course because it was written by someone
from the palace you don't speak in the
wood lacquer get the rest out speaking I
didn't know you understand it but I sort
of thought we do what they never say he
understands the limits of constitutional
monarchy in effectively I didn't they
were saying he's campaigning on issues
from architecture to genetically
modified food will stop when he's King
because otherwise it's going to be quite
tricky doing the king speech my
government will massively expand genetic
modified dude oh my dead body let's go
back to school and he needs in class
she's a while she's already had a frosty
reception at the school gates hasn't she
I think so she tweeted a letter that had
been put into the kids book bags about
about encouraging people to give some
money for a joint present she changed
the names and everything to make an
anonymous and then tweeted that her
daughter would like a unicorn marlane no
class everybody in that school that
she's mocked publicly will know who
those kids are no there's parents on
when other parents took it up with her
she said let's talk about this in
private well no class you didn't talk
about it in private when you put it out
and Twitter I love and actually knows if
she was going to her parents she's
talking licking and she's talking about
the modern turn with the school party
for children the goody bags which I know
some of my parents think they're so
expensive and they they're frightened if
we don't realize you going sir ones
their children the miata now that these
parents wanted cash to buy their child a
kindle by your own child who killed any
threat dang lumps of other kids to buy
no I got as I've done a lot of sympathy
or watching yeah as a parent when my
kids have gone to parties if somebody
said they would like money because they
buy something unrelieved instead of
having to go out and find a we find a
president presence in our class and I've
always been at Sonya five and ask kevin
yeah i never got invited to parties what
I especially like was about that the
letter was only direct dressed two
ladies clearly there are no dads at them
yeah well
ladies the tedious stuff like dying
let's not forget Milan class knew this
would get extended because she has got
50 teeth thousand photos onto a few more
than you desperate for publicity she's
got it all right finally it turns out
that darbyshire is a hotbed for devil
worship who would have thought it was
over both so beware of course the local
MP Dennis Skinner now he's known as the
Beast of Bolsover so honey but I said
the set e said the 17 I probably said
the Satan is cause less embarrassing
admitting you at all i lo but the church
the Church of Satan Eve denounces this
it says no we haven't got 17 members so
they probably are tall yeah yeah yeah
they said they think it's a prank that
you know there was a pity gonna plug
Dennis Skinner spoke it's very
compelling my hand in writing it oh
right you know have you told the tax
plan right I declare it receive I unlike
you to your people and all things of the
week now right we're moving you moving
on at Katie Cutler you're up this week
this is you and Ruth no it's not it's
the angel of the north Katie Cutler who
raised money crowd sourcing and using
using Twitter and Facebook and so on for
Allen Barnes a four foot six disabled
elderly guy partially sighted who was
mugged by toe ragging in gateshead more
than caught thermal pads it's absolutely
wonderful he's touched in restart his
life and it's gonna fun to buy a new
home and maybe I go back to the house
because he thought he'd be scared was
that sweetheart used to isn't he I hope
the total Raghu did it was just say
cringing somewhere waiting for that tap
on the show yeah good for her and we
wish him every happiness so we're
sending her up but you are sending down
this week oh yeah that's right the
energy regulator which is advising
people to save money but i have appt at
lunch cancel your gym membership well
people are pressed because of higher
fuel prices why doesn't off Jim just do
its job and get those prices down
instead of being stupid Patrignano
priate that suggesting ways we could all
cut our cloth separate it's
extraordinary and for once I'm agreement
McGwire complete reminds me of when a
certain Tory Minister said when people
were cold in the north where a bubbly
hat in bed I'll have to write this debt
this down this is one Dave agreed yeah
right on to unit rocio sending ausgabe
down you are sending up half a league
I think this is fantastic a great fan of
tequila Mockingbird we never thought
there was another book it's now
transpired in fact she wrote another
book which was about the characters 15
years beyond she regular blackshear a
shower first it's called a better watch
ya and the publisher said actually you
should write how they were earlier she's
now going to publish the manuscripts
been found it's going to be published
it's going to be the publishing
sensation of the year in every prize up
top every best my god I want it so yeah
it's already setting sales records
because it stopping five runs out
topping pre-orders but it may not be
very good well we will send her up
sending down though this is the water
Pig Elvis one of when I heard about the
war thought it was a raving yeah when I
heard about the real water because the
reference to kevin mcguire but actually
this is the Noah was the multi pig that
killed his wife and children in Bristol
Zoo I don't if they were officially
married but one friend it's not quite
layout in the animal world accurate
should be a more info brimir route do
you take this warthog Henry your lawful
and wedding all times go see because
there was a monkey they'll in an
ornamental pond and it got eaten my
daughter are you offering spot of birds
are you under the rollaway I'm gonna
come from Bristol they started going on
at that crystal do you say they have the
highest standards of animal welfare
education and conservation not security
well that it may take consolation when
the big get the other p you know if
you're not on drugs you should go down
the GP yeah and thank you so much for
joining us for our review of the week
don't forget you can catch Kevin and
Andrew in action on the sky news press
preview along with the other paper
review is the take a first look at the
newspapers every evening 1030 and 1130
and sky knees you must stop laughing
about dead beings will be back from or
next week so for now it's goodbye from
them goodbye and it's goodbye from me
goodbye